so much weird stuff has been happening
that's
it it feels like it has to be a
conspiracy you know what i mean
definitely like how how is this possible
all these weird things are going on
and now at once and now it does feel
like
there's some aliens aliens some sort of
something driving everything
aliens is it aliens check this out oh oh
let's talk about it senate intelligence
committee confirms the u.s navy has a
ufo task force
my question here right off the bat is
wouldn't it have been the air force
i'm already i'm already suspect they do
i heard i heard this like kind of
sort of joke do you know uh who has the
biggest air force in the world
the navy the u.s air force the united
states
oh do you know who has the second
biggest air force in the world uh
the navy the u.s navy so
like our military man wow yeah i thought
the first one was a trick
yeah i was like i got this chest that's
the trick though right you say like
juno who has the biggest air force look
like america that's right you know the
second biggest
the u.s navy right right right so the
air force and the navy i don't know if
that's true or whatever
maybe actually yeah my understanding is
the army has more boats than the navy
too
that's crazy oh interesting because uh i
could be wrong about this i'm sure the
people who are listening know better
but the army has a ton of boats they
just don't have big destroyers and stuff
like that right but they do have a lot
of boats
so like lake boats and river boats they
probably got some big boats
yeah probably yeah for sure like cargo
ships and stuff and
different branches man you got to move
that space boats how many how many
boats does the space force have many i
hope i'm sure they've got a bunch
of got some boats yeah man they they
probably have the third most amount of
uh airplanes
all right so check this check check
check us out okay so listen
in in i'm all you know because it's 2020
and everybody is saying like what's next
aliens
and then we have these two actual major
sightings check this out
where are we here we go mysterious
lights spotted flashing in houston sky
leave onlookers startled
because they moved too fast to be drones
or fire lanterns
a string of strange lights were seen
floating around each other
in the sky over houston on wednesday
night this is a couple days ago mind you
check this out
ufo sighting in miami sparks social
media meltdown
this other video i don't know where it's
from shows weird vortexes
lined up in the sky yeah i want to see
that one i actually have it on my phone
i probably should have
texted it or something i actually have a
buddy who lives in new york who
has sent me he takes videos
and he sent me some you know videos of
objects that he saw
weird aliens they it doesn't make any
sense he's like
i don't understand what this is and it's
not only that it's been going on for
over over two years this has been
happening to him he's been showing me
these videos he's like i i was
he like came he was coming over we were
gonna play magic and he's like dude
look at this this was just outside
walking down your your street and i'm
like looking at it i'm like
what is it it doesn't make any sense
it's i don't understand they're they're
popping up everywhere you know
what is happening it's the uh it's the
the the camera objects for the third
person video game
and so you can see them and you're like
what is that and what you don't see is
like the little guy flying around
like you know and he's got the camera's
you can't see the camera because it's
your perspective or maybe it's like
the cursor for the mouse for whoever's
playing the game
we're just like what is that they're
dragging down and picks you up you're
like
and when you're getting abducted you're
not getting brought into a ship you're
just getting drag and drop
oh no that's exactly what's happening so
assuming we
you know are we in a simulation
one of the you know the question is what
is the simulation and why would it why
would why would you argue that it's a
simulation in fact right so
we got these aliens look aliens i'm not
they're not really aliens i don't know
what they are but you can see
let me see if i can i can play this it's
like weird lights flying over miami
these weird uh vortexes
vortices what's the word vertices
vortices good words this is not playing
do we have maybe maybe over here we can
here we go
weird lights a video from houston texas
on wednesday night appears to show a
string of flickering lights in the sky
moving around each other before
disappearing completely aliens
what could they be oh we got a video of
it
whoa you can't really see anything can
you make it bigger yes
whoa we got some audio
there from the sky
i don't see them moving
that's the sky over there look at this
what is this they're just chilling
they're not moving though
there's anything like it for me it looks
like stars it is so
weird i don't see movies i wish i could
see it in person because it looks pretty
different than on video
that's that's the other thing too here
what you just said yeah it looks
different on video
i wish you could see it in person yep
there's been a bunch of things i've seen
in the sky
that i've like whoa i got a film and i'm
like you can't get it every time the
moon is beautiful it's like i want a
picture of this no
yeah man so uh what do you think it is
what do i are you asking me personally
what do i think yeah yeah yeah like
what's your best
w what was your if you'd make a bet if i
was like yo we're going to put some
chips down on this
i i want it to be aliens i would love
you know it's like you you just said
like we are stagnating as a culture our
human humanity like what are we doing
with our lives it's like alien if aliens
actually came around we'd be like
whoa we gotta check ourselves but what
if what if they have a really weird
creepy culture
and they want us to adhere to it you
know that might unify us what if they
colonize us
you know they come here and they already
are what if they're like yeah
i didn't always wear beanie all the time
yeah now i just
wake up with a beanie it's weird in in
all seriousness
maybe humans are being in a sense
domesticated oh
interesting so like we talked about this
before if you come so
i talked about some on the rogan podcast
couple months ago when i was saying like
i had this idea for a cool story
where aliens come to earth and offer
humanity all this really great
technology
and knowledge and most humans accept it
and then a bunch of humans resist and
say no you know
the alphas humanity must be you know to
itself we must we're responsible for
ourselves we reject your weird ways
the offices and then in hundreds of
years
the the human beings that sided with the
aliens are now
five feet tall scrawny but armored to
the teeth with crazy technology can they
can fly
and they desperately love the aliens now
because the ones that succeeded in the
alien culture were the ones who loved
the aliens the most
and generated favor okay and the humans
that resist
who are six feet something ripped yeah
the alpha males
they're wolves and so the story quite
literally is
humans raid a farm and then an alien
comes running out and then a bunch of
humans with jet packs come out and
they're short and
and squeaky and they've got crazy armor
and force fields and they're like
and so quite literally the idea is when
we have a dog go out
to fight with wolves we have spiked
collars because the wolves go for the
neck and they can't
and that's a technological advancement
wolves don't have because the the other
wolves were bred into dogs and teamed up
with us
so it's like the aggression is bred out
of the species
yeah they're given advanced technologies
and then they can serve
the you know they're interesting because
the sjws is like toxic masculinity
or like you know getting rid of the
family
family no more alpha males it's like
that's how we've gotten as far as we've
gotten they want you to be obedient
they want you to be non-aggressive oh
man they want you uh
to be gender neutral you know they don't
i don't say they want you to be but
it's encouraged you know it's like and
protected and not that i have any
i'm not saying i have an issue with that
i'm saying it's part of like
you know we we we we gender neutralify
our dogs you know what we got to do we
got to keep these aliens confused and
we're going to spin the ufo so they
can't figure out what's going on yes
let's keep them real dizzy
aliens so long story short aliens
let's say let's say i love when i was
talking to joe about this and i was like
you really think the galactic federation
is going to let us in when our planet's
ruled by multiple governments
he said he's like i don't think there's
a galactic federation yeah i'm like i
know there's
not that's the joke like that's what
you're taking from this
but uh let's say there was
that's the joke it's it's it's a half
joke like the point is
if there really were aliens they're not
going to come and greet us no
unless we're like a farm and they're
yeah domesticating
in in a sense you know making us more
docile and non-aggressive
this is a real question serious i'm very
serious
do you think hillary's an alien no okay
why would i think
hillary was an alien i don't know i kind
of do you think [ __ ]
well no no with what you're saying is
true they're trying to domesticate us
and like
no no they're just in league with the
aliens man come on yeah the lizard
people and the aliens are working
together so
this is this is the thing this is the
joke i bring up right so
one the one thing i really hate about
conspiracy theorists is
if you're going to jump through 50 hoops
to come to a conclusion why that
conclusion
yeah right it's like if you can if you
can just i'll tell you what
if i got to think of all these different
coincidences that that add up to a story
i'll make the story way more fun right
yeah
you know no not lizard people it's
interdimensional oh no alex jones has
that one covered
just make it more fun the wizards it's
actually merlin
and uh his school of
wizards frozen in time have come back
with ancient knowledge
and if i'm going to make something up
why wouldn't i make up something crazy
you know what i mean
now we have these i saw this post where
these parents are like
so we have our our six-year-old who
we've for
that our six-year-old's entire life have
said harry potter's
real they're yeah they're actually a
wizard and we want how do we
what can we do to like continue this on
as long as we can
we think that when when our our kid
finally
figures it out it'll be better to
because they'll they'll understand
hardship
geez oh my gosh just like
i can't this is this is what people are
doing now though i mean it's
it's almost like santa claus so but
they're teaching but
but the reason i bring that up is
because what you were just saying it's
like
they're not only are they jumping to
these conclusions through all these
hoops
they're teaching their children this
that this is this is fact
and it's like you trust your parents
your parents obviously are
you're they're your only connection to
the world so
they're teaching kids that yeah
everybody harry potter is real
yeah you're a wizard and you're actually
a wizard you're awesome
their kid actually believes it it's a
wizard and then what happens when the
world collapses
and they're made fun of and they're
insane for the rest of their lives
they become an angry ring
person that has no purpose and feels
like the entire world's against them so
this is the point i was making about
you know making up your own conspiracy
it's like if you're going to claim that
that the globalists are trying to take
over
just give them a good fun reason
galactic federation bone if you're going
to make something up i can make
something up too right yeah right
and so hey i think my theory makes more
sense
why is it that hillary and biden and
these
these these you know architects of a
global one world government
wanted to happen so that we can be
inducted in the galactic federation baby
yeah all the sweet technology
immortality travel the stars we can't
get it because we're too busy fighting
each other
right now now the reason that makes no
sense is because you know they want to
go to war with russia and stuff like
that yeah like hillary yeah yeah so
that's why i don't believe in any of
these you know whatever i think when it
comes to these mysterious lights
flashing and flying around
military attack man you think about that
it's just the easiest explanation
it does make the most sense you're right
it's you know we we developed what was
like 100 years ago we made the nuke
was it 180 years ago yeah yeah i guess
so
come on man what have we been working on
since then who knows just regular
commercial grade military attacks
there's probably undercover stuff you
ever see do you ever see star trek um
which one not uh into the into darkness
oh yeah
i love those yes so the the the
federation guy is secretly developing a
massive war machine and they don't
realize it
and nobody knew not even the people in
the in the in the in starfleet
why wouldn't the u.s government doing
something similar so you have a bunch of
these these private military contractors
making crazy weapons
and i'm sure there's some companies you
don't know about you never heard of you
never will hear of
getting getting funding and doing crazy
things and i know a lot of people
respond with you think the government
could actually
you know make this thing work like the
military could
no i don't i absolutely don't think the
military i do not
i think a private company kept off the
books given unlimited funding can do
crazy things if they have no
restrictions
yeah weird experiments disregarding you
know any safety regulations laws because
you know they want the power i mean i
mean they were doing mk ultra in what
the 70s
yeah like 60s and 70s my mind
manipulation it's like
that was in the 70s that was that was 50
years ago
imagine what what are they doing now
have they perfected 40 years 50 years
yeah
manipulation probably maybe look at what
p
how people are being manipulated into
everything we're seeing now like
is covid real half the people are like i
don't even believe it's real anymore
it's just conspiracy now my favorite
conspiracy theory is that trump
is one of the top elites of the you know
global architects
right and that we've got people now
begging for law and order this is what
i've been saying like because of all the
chaos
you've got you know 10 years ago 15
years ago a lot of people were like
no police state no government takeover
small government right now
a lot of these people are saying like
trump stop the violence stop the
violence bring in the military
you're like now you've got people who
normally would never do this begging for
for
you know order and they're cheering for
trump to do it so
we'll see if trump wins i see a much
much larger
or louder i should say call for
individual accountability
and it's like we're seeing it people are
guns are flying off the shelves
yeah leftists are buying guns everyone's
like well the 2a argument's over
and it's like well good and bad
well why is it bad because we're in a
position where we need the 2a
and now we have a bunch of people who
aren't trained like waving their guns
around at their spouses on their front
porches and their bare feet
that kind of troubled me a little bit
yeah a bunch of untrained people
who don't know it's crazy because you
know i would never
i would never claim that i'm an expert
in any way any guns and i know not to
point a weapon at your wife
that's a good thing i mean yeah you
really don't like her yeah i guess
well how about trump made him do it it's
probably that's just
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 pm if you
want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode